Patrick Stewart has played Captain John
Luke Picard since 1987 in Star Trek the
Next Generation in 2020 the
award-winning actor returned to that
beloved role for the spin-off series
that's called Star Trek Picard it's on
Paramount plus we're happy to tell you
that the series is now entering its
third and single tier here final season
and in this clip Admiral Picard is
reunited with Captain Will Riker as they
prepare for a risky mission to rescue an
old friend
I'm not sure about this plan because
it's not really a plan it's a ruse
that's the part I don't like you and I
are two highly ranked members of
Starfleet doing a routine surprise
inspection we could be called Marshall
for this you could lose everything you
work for only if we get caught you got
to sell this
come on Admiral show me your inspection
face give me one of those rigid
disapproving sour Expressions you're
famous for
there it is there it is there it is
he just said show me your inspection
face yeah did you bring your inspection
face today Patrick Stewart um I brought
everything that could possibly legally
without offense be examined
no examination here today we're happy to
say but I love looking at you back then
in 1987 and now when you first took on
this role in 1987 did you have any
expectations You couldn't possibly have
thought it would go this long what were
your expectations back then
well they weren't High because I'd never
heard of Star Trek and uh I I talked to
a handful of people whom I knew and they
all said look
you can't revive an iconic show like
Star Trek you're probably not making it
the first season right so you know make
a little bit of money for the first time
in your life maybe you meet some nice
girls you know you can get a suntan go
home yes I know several years later I
know and so how we sit here 35 years
later still talking about it what does
this character mean to you I've been
very blessed in my career with the roles
that I played
but nothing has the importance like
Jean-Luc Picard and if you tell me that
I would be saying that when I first got
the role I would have laughed in your
face
um But as time went by and I saw the
impact that Star Trek could have on
people and their lives
um the diversity of the show it's belief
in honesty fair play equality all those
Elements which kind of get a little
sketchy in real these days in real life
in real life yeah there's other ways
that Star Trek has affected other people
but I'm interested in how it's affected
you where does the character End and You
Begin well I mean those are the lot
those are Picard and Patrick Stewart and
by season two they had done that and I
really didn't know where one began and
the other one left off I didn't have
arthritic fingers in those days of
course yeah it was much more comfortable
yeah
I
it changed my life there was nothing
in my life that was not affected and now
comes it comes to an end this Is It
season three the final season the final
Adventure
how do you feel about it this is the
thing about Star Trek the nature of it
you can't say it's over right I mean
look at there are five or six different
emanations of Star Trek right on the air
now the impact of the show has been
extraordinary was there a particular
moment where you knew this was so much
bigger than what you realized
yes I was
um almost at once when we began shooting
the first season of Star Trek
um
we were being invited to conventions and
and uh science fiction conventions
particularly and when I got there I was
taken into a back door and uh we were
waiting to begin and I was ready and uh
I said
is there anybody out there
and they said
well yes and I said oh well that's good
just checking that's all they announced
me and I walked on Wow and 2 000 people
Rose
began cheering and applauding and I was
utterly unexpected for that it was
incredible I love when you said you
walked out to a round of applause
because that is certainly how we feel
about you of course
Applause continued success hey what's
left for you because you know you were
80 something but you still got a lot to
get started yeah um
I well there there is a movie and uh
that's possible in the future but
principally I think the moment has come
when I'm gonna return to the life
theater to the stage all right in fact
there are a couple of Shakespeare roles
I've never played and wow and i i people
are talking about that now so that's
probably the next step you may be able
to get one without an audition I think
they might go around maybe maybe maybe
the first episode of Star Trek Picard
season three the final is streaming now
on Paramount plus which as you know CBS
is a part of Paramount global